last question this is a little weird one
but you've called yourself
crazy in the past uh
first of all on a scale of one to ten
how crazy would you say
are you oh i mean it depends how you you
know when you compare me to elon musk
and anthony lewandowski not so crazy
so like like a seven let's go with six
six yes six what uh
i like seven seven's a good number seven
all right well yeah i'm sure
day by day changes right so but you're
in that
in that area what uh
in thinking about that what do you think
is the role of madness
is that a feature or a bug if you were
to
dissect your brain so okay from like a
like mental health lens on crazy i'm not
sure i really believe in that
i'm not sure i really believe in like a
lot of that stuff
right this concept of okay you know when
you get over to like
like like like hardcore bipolar and
schizophrenia these things are clearly
real somewhat biological and then over
here on the spectrum you have like
add and oppositional defiance disorder
and
these things that are like wait this is
normal spectrum human behavior like this
isn't
you know where's the the line here and
why is this like a
problem so there's this whole this you
know the neurodiversity of humanity is
huge like people think i'm always on
drugs people are saying this to me on my
streams and like guys you know like i'm
real open with my drug use i'd tell you
if i was on drugs
i mean i had like a cup of coffee this
morning but other than that this is just
me
you're witnessing my brain in action
so so the word madness doesn't even uh
make sense and then you're in the rich
neurodiversity of
humans i think it makes sense but only
for
like some insane extremes like if you
are actually
like visibly hallucinating
um you know that's okay but there is the
kind of spectrum on which you stand out
like that that's uh like if i were to
look you know at decorations on a
christmas tree or something like that
like if you were a decoration out that
would catch my eye like
that thing is sparkly what if
whatever the hell that thing is uh
there's something to that
just like refusing to be um
boring or maybe boring is the wrong word
but to um
yeah i mean be willing to sparkle
you know it's it's like somewhat
constructed i mean
i am who i choose to be uh
i'm gonna say things as true as i can
see them i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna lie and but that's a
really important feature in itself so
like whatever the newer diversity of
your
whatever your brain is not putting um
constraints on it that force it to to
fit into the mold of what society is
like
defines what you're supposed to be so
you're one of the specimens
that that doesn't mind being
yourself being right
is super important except at the expense
of being wrong
without breaking that apart i think it's
a beautiful way to end it and george
you're one of the most special humans i
know it's truly an honor to talk to you
thanks so much for doing it thank you
for having me
you